bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde
ravi de vous retrouver au sommaire ce
soir urgence sur le pouvoir d'achat
c'est devenu le grand thème de ces
législatives les prix du gazole s'envole
à nouveau les prix alimentaires pourrait
dépasser les 6% cet été le gouverneur de
la banque de france alerte l'inflation
va augmenter va s'installer dans la
durée alors pourquoi le gouvernement
attend pour prendre de nouvelles mesures
et si il faut en prendre les quelles
seraient les plus efficaces on en débat
dans un instant qu avec nos invités sur
ce plateau notre grand témoin ce soir à
filmer la guerre dans le donbass comme
vous ne l'avez jamais vu une immersion à
hauteur d'homme tourné en 2020 avant
l'offensive heures russe pendant trois
mois il a pu s'infiltrer seul au sein du
30e bataillon de l'armée ukrainienne
filmé en noir et blanc ces jeunes
soldats racontent leur quotidien sur la
ligne de fond tranché c'est le titre de
son film hell ou bureau celui qu'il a
réalisé sera avec nous dans la deuxième
partie enfin nous retrouverons nos a
franchi pour leur parti pris ce soir
carrenet campagne législative signé elsa
mondain gaba qui s'arrête sur la
stratégie de marine le pen le retour de
fatiha bouge à lattes et qui va
interpeller eric piolle sur le burqini
dans les piscines à grenoble et isabelle
lasserre qui nous dira pourquoi selon
elle les ukrainiens ont déjà gagné voilà
pour le fun c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'être au
rendez-vous le gouvernement peut-il
attendre les législatives pour agir sur
le pouvoir d'achat grand débat ce soir
sur l'inflation qui frappe au
portefeuille des français bonsoir
mathieu plane et merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes économiste lfc e
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques de sciences po paris
bonsoir raphaël legendre ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau journaliste
économique à l'opinion bonsoir alain
bazot soyez le bienvenu président et
l'ufc que choisir vous nous direz quel
sont vos préconisations et ce qui vous
préoccupe le plus dans cette flambée des
prix au supermarché et à la pompe mais
on commence avec mon camarade stéphane
blakowski bonsoir si j'ai bien compris
soir myriam bon sens les cieux
l'inflation est là et pour un petit
moment
[Musique]
le regard de blacko comme ça que soir si
j'ai bien compris votre billet sera
compris myriam ce matin sur france inter
donc le gouverneur de la banque de
france a annoncé une bonne ou une
mauvaise nouvelle donc question rituelle
parcours on commence la bonne comme
j'aime bien commencer par la bonne est
ce que je suis vous donne la bonne
nouvelle françois villeroy de galhau
sont celles de notre gouverneur il a
promis que la pression allait baisser
donc ça c'est quand même chose dont on
peut se réjouir puisque je vous rappelle
que le mois dernier on a atteint le
chiffre de cheval sous le contrôle de
rafah et 4,8 pour cent qui est un record
depuis presque quarante ans donc tant
par le bout c'est quand même une bonne
chose bon ça c'est sale c'est la bonne
nouvelle la mauvaise hélas la mauvaise
nouvelle c'est que cette bonne nouvelle
dont je vous parle c'est pas pour tout
de suite en fait ça c'est promis juré
l'inflation va baisser mais l'année
prochaine donc en clair ça veut dire que
les prix vont continuer d'augmenter bas
au moins jusqu'à la fin de l'année on
écoute le gouverneur quand on regarde
devant nous cette inflation élevée
devraient durer encore cette année et
commencer à baisser au début de l'année
prochaine en fonction des prix de
l'énergie ce qui est très important
c'est que l'inflation devrait revenir
autour de 2% qui est son bon niveau
d'ici 2024 ce que je voudrais dire c'est
que c'est pas seulement nos prévisions
c'est notre engagement avec christine
lagarde et la banque centrale européenne
alors comment il compte se tenir cet
engagement cet engagement le gouverneur
de la banque de france et la bce pour
réduire ou pour maîtriser l'inflation à
2 % je vais être honnête moi je fais pas
bien la différence entre ce qui ressort
du passif est de l'actif dans un bilan
comptable donc ça serait un peu
présomptueux expliquer comment on fait
pour baisser l'inflation et en même
temps ça n'a pas l'air si compliqué je
vais vous dire c'est que toutes les
banques centrales font exactement la
même chose regardez la feb donc la
banque centrale américaine a augmenté
ses taux assez récemment mais c'est
pareil avec la banque d'angleterre qui
elle augmente régulièrement ses taux
depuis je crois décembre et qui continue
à le faire donc nous avec la bce pour
l'instant on est encore là mais se
prêtent encore de l'argent à un taux
négatif donc bien il va y avoir une
inversion on va à notre tour commençait
à faire monter les taux dixit françois
villeroy de galhau peux pas me prononcer
sur le calendrier
disons qu à partir de l'été je pense que
la banque centrale européenne relèvera
progressivement ses taux d'intérêt donc
là on en est à une bonne nouvelle la
façon c'est bientôt fini une mauvaise
doit être pas tout de suite
là il faut que vous parle de la très
mauvaise nouvelle mais ce qui en plus
fait une très mauvaise il ya une très
mauvaise nouvelle et bavarde courageuse
haut et fort mais le quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est fini tôt voilà c'est dit il faut
s'y tenir il ya eu la crise du coc vite
donc on avait vraiment mis à
l'arrière-plan les questions de la dette
après la campagne présidentielle on l'a
carrément mis sous le tapis la question
de la bête d'ailleurs le monde avait
carrément fait un article sur ce sujet
mais vidarte pendant la campagne et tous
les candidats ont promis de dépenser des
milliards pour soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat même si macron a peut-être été
plus raisonnable que mélenchon et le pen
mon problème c'est qu'il a été lui donc
ses promesses il faut qui les tiennent
donc on sait que pour les dépenses n'a
déjà pas mal qui sont prévues il y avait
là pris par le bouquet tarifaire depuis
longtemps mais qui vont être prolongées
l'a remis sur le carburant le chèque
alimentaire mais il a aussi fait des
promesses de baisses d impôts pour 15
milliards la sérénité la redevance c'est
dans les provinces comment voulez vous
revenir sur vos promesses vous avions
parlé mais qu est ce qu elle l impôt sur
la production les droits de succession
donc bien sûr que le gouvernement le
gouverneur de la banque de france ne
fait pas de politique vous doutez bien
n'empêche ce matin il n'a pas l'air de
soutenir président de la république
entre le nouveau président de la
république c'est mon devoir de rappeler
que
l'illusion d'une dette qui est sans
limites et sans coûts c'est une illusion
très séduisante mais très dangereuse
globalement il faut bien dire
qu'aujourd'hui s'offrir entre guillemets
plus de dépenses ou moins d'impôts ça
veut dire plus de dettes ça veut dire
plus de charges d'intérêts ça veut dire
moins de marge de manoeuvre pour
l'avenir
donc je résume le dilemme du président
macron soit il ne réduit pas la dette il
se fâche avec le gouverneur de la banque
de france qui est embêtant soit qui
cherche à réduire la dette mais là il se
passe avait beaucoup beaucoup plus de
monde ce qui est sans doute encore plus
embêtant voilà un bon deal m il est posé
sur la table merci merci stéphane pour
votre regard on va re déroulé parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses dans le
billet de stéphane ce soit je vais
commencer avec vous alain bazot on va
partir du diagnostic
les prix du gazole frôlé 2% c'est parmi
les plus chers d'europe les deux euros
pardonnez moi j'ai regardé on est juste
après l'allemagne et les pays du nord au
supermarché c'est quasiment tous les
produits alimentaires de première
nécessité qui flambent ticket de caisse
augmenté entre 10 et 15 % en mars
dernier qu'est ce qui est le plus
préoccupant pour vous comment vous voyez
le moment dans lequel on est vous qui
défendez les consommateurs ce qui est
préoccupant c'est ici l'ensemble les
choses qui s'ajoute puisque les gens à
la fois ont besoin de l'énergie et ils
ont besoin de s'alimenter donc si la la
la la convergence de l'augmentation sur
des dépenses qui sont des dépenses
contraintes en plus parce qu'il faut se
chauffer enfin là avec le temps un peu
moins mais il faut quand même de l'eau
chaude il faut se déplacer surtout pour
le travail vraiment des activités et
puis il faut se il faut se nourrir donc
c'est l'ensemble qui est extrêmement
préoccupant sachant qu on oublie souvent
des portions de population parle
beaucoup de du prix à la pompe pour on
oublie par exemple le prix du gaz du
fioul domestique pour tous les gens qui
se chauffe ça ils sont complètement hors
des radars on n'en parle pas dans les
campagnes les gens son équipe est
largement en nylon pas de gaz de ville
libre la dérogation que le problème il
est là et
alors on le mesure la
une ces deux mesures nous la mesure et
on a sorti un taux d'inflation qu'on
estime un peu plus proche de la réalité
combien il est de 5 3 donc c'est
paraissait pas énormément va pas rentrer
dans les discussions sur la pertinence
en tout cas ça va monter de toute façon
ça va monter et alors c'est vrai qu'on
parle du je sais pas si on en parle
maintenant mais on parle beaucoup du
duduk quoi qu'il en coûte et de la fin
du quoi qu'il en coûte et moi je peux ce
jour la question mais il ya la question
du combien ça rapporte parce que le
premier bénéficiaire de l'augmentation
des prix c'est l'état est ce qu'une tva
à 20% sur l'énergie sur l'électricité
qui est un bien essentiel ça interroge
quand même sur la légitimité de cette
fiscalité donc on parle toujours du
combien savent où il faudrait
il faudra abandonner toute façon faire
le calcul est regardée l'augmentation
des prix non seulement évidemment de
l'énergie qui avaient 1% mais de tout le
reste combien ça rapporte et à l'état et
on sera là nous pour faire le calcul
parce qu'on dit toujours ça nous coûte
ça nous coûte mais ça nous rapporte on
voit les uns dans les solutions
éventuelles
distribution en baissant les recettes
fiscales liée à la hausse des prix
mathieu plane des économistes qui se
sont plantés là sur l'inflation faut le
reconnaître à l' ocde
christine lagarde ont tout le monde
disait elle sera maîtrisée c'était
certes légèrement avant la guerre en
ukraine mais mais quand même là on
s'attend à quoi à 10 % d'inflation dans
les prochains mois je m'engagerai pas
sur 10 %
ils se sont plantés on se plante
d'ailleurs collectivement mais pour des
bonnes raisons si on peut se planter 1
c'est à dire que effectivement il ya des
événements internationaux quand même
assez particulier
on a vu ça va commencer déjà à la fin de
l'année 2020 terrain avec le rebond nos
micros et la stratégie zéro co vide en
chine ce qui était pas forcément dans
les tuyaux cette époque là la guerre en
ukraine s'était pas non plus forcément
dans les tuyaux on l'a bien vu donc
c'est vrai que les conditions globales
économiques ont
la guerre vous vous renforcez les
difficultés d'approvisionnement donc ça
crée des tensions sur la chaîne
d'approvisionnement c'est plutôt
inflationnistes qui vous manque des
composants industriels et puis l'autre
effet c'est d'énergie et c'est le choc
d'énergie il faut pas oublier que la
russie d'un plus un des plus gros
producteur au monde de gaz et de pétrole
le choc énergétique et pas
voilà exactement ce qui était vu il ya
six mois c'était que le choc d'inflation
était provisoire parce qu'on avait des
goulots d'étranglement mais pas qui
était il n'y avait pas une nouvelle
donne géopolitique c'est à dire c'était
pas une donne géopolitique où vous avez
un gros producteur mondial qui serait
petit à petit sortie du marché et donc
là les marchés ont anticipé ont intégré
on n'est pas dans un embargo on peut
rentrer en plus dans un rôle des prix de
l'énergie qui peut être durable pétrole
ou gaz très
sûr et voilà est ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que nous on produit pas
d'hydrocarbures donc on les importe donc
forcément un choc sur les hydrocarbures
c'est un choc très négatif pour
l'économie française parce qu'on a payé
plus cher notre essence notre chauffage
et états et donc sera chaude très
négatif sur le port de chats et la
question maintenant c'est ce qu'on
appelle ses effets de second tour c'est
à dire comment les salaires vont réagir
à ça c'est à dire qui va encaisser ses
portes pour perdre pour l'achat qu'est
ce que fait l'état pour compenser les
perdants est ce que les entreprises
prennent une part des pertes
éventuellement sur leurs marges c'est ça
les grands enjeux des mécanismes
d'indexation qui existe aussi deux smic
des prestations et ses dernières
solutions est en effet très particulier
oui on a l'impression que voilà personne
ne l'avait véritablement anticipé en
tout cas pas à ce niveau-là bonsoir
christophe ramaux jeu et merci d'être
avec nous cet économiste membre des
économistes atterrés maître de
conférences à l'université paris 1 je
cherche dans mes petits papiers le nom
de votre dernier ouvrage que j'ai à pour
seulement promis de citer une économie
républicaine c'est aux éditions de boue
qu'on vient d'entendre le gouverneur de
la banque de france françois villeroy de
galhau qui nous dit c'est maîtrisable en
2024 on revient à 2 % vous y croyez on a
l'impression qu'on est parti vers une
envolée la certitude est tel que deux
bourses en 2024 c'est une tendance
possible je pense que c'est la plus
probable après voilà mais c'est la plus
probable tout simplement parce que le
déterminant fondamental de l'inflation
c'est les coûts de production et donc là
on a un coût conjoncturel est liée à ce
qu'ils étaient ce qui vient d'être
évoquée l'automne notamment la la guerre
en ukraine mais le déterminer au
principal ce sont les salaires or on vit
dans un monde
en particulier en europe d'ailleurs
peut-être moins en partie aux états unis
mais en particulier en europe où il ya
de l'austérité salariale où il ya le
libre échange et donc il ya ya ya ya une
compression sur les salaires comment
dire qui à mon avis d'ailleurs il
faudrait relâché pour que l'économie se
porte mieux mais il ya une compression
qui est elle sur les salaires que cette
fameuse boucle l'inflation aux salaires
bas elle se met pas elle se met pas en
prendre voilà donc le déterminant
principal de l'inflation c'est d'abord
et avant tout les coûts de production et
parmi eux les salaires les salaires
entendue au sens large en mettant dans
toutes les cotisations sociales et donc
là je pense pas qu'ils aient de 2-2-2 de
pression risque
comprend le choc je pensais faute à lire
les deux il ya il ya l'horizon de long
terme très bien qui est plutôt mauvais
pas mais il ya un choc à court terme qui
est très très très importants et en
particulier pour les ménages et qu'il
faut qu'il faut gérer il ya les deux
dimensions a essayé de répondre moi je
voudrais comprendre vraiment pour bien
posé le constat le diagnostic raphaël
legendre on nous dit croissance modérée
ces termes du gouverneur de la banque de
france en tout cas 020 décès rien
quasiment c'est pas grand-chose bon on
redémarre c'est sûr mais là encore les
conjoncturistes tablaient sur beaucoup
plus quand on a peu de croissance qu'on
a une envolée des prix est ce qu'on
craint la stagflation à c'est la
définition même de la station
effectivement on a une économie
française
qui n'a pas progressé au premier
trimestre croissance zéro c'était une
mauvaise surprise on s'attendait à à
bien davantage que ce soit la banque de
france où l'insee on est sur 0 de 0,25
pour le prochain trimestre et on sait
d'ores et déjà qu'on ne sera pas au
rendez-vous la croissance cette année il
ya beaucoup de déterminants
macroéconomiques qui assombrissent le
tableau la première bien évidemment et
la guerre en ukraine dont on ne sait pas
combien de temps va durer ce choc
énergétique sur les prix qui impacte
l'ensemble de l'appareil productif on
parlait des coûts de production les
anticipations sur les coûts de
production sont bien au delà de ceux de
l'inflation réelle on est sur du + 25 %
quasiment donc il va y avoir des
pressions inflationnistes à la hausse 2
court terme de moyen terme est de plus
long terme la transition énergétique va
coûter cher c'est près de 400 milliards
d'euros d'investissements annuels qu'il
faudra au sein de l'europe pour assurer
cette transition énergétique souvient de
la phrase je découvre la phrase de bruno
le maire qui allait marquer les esprits
le choc énergétique qu'on traverse est
comparable aux chocs pétroliers de soi
sans briller c'est à peu près ça c'est à
peu près ça au niveau du cou qu'il y
avait une spirale inflationniste à ce
moment-là et hélas si on vient très
largement dire supérieurs on n'est pas
tout à fait dans le même qu'un tas dire
qu'en gros les lèveraient augmentant les
salaires augmentaient était anticipé en
était d'ailleurs à l'époque est donc
complet et là on est d'accord c'est pas
ça qui nous fait parce que les salaires
n'augmentent pas qu effectivement mais
c'est surveillé c'est super de boer a
parlé des solutions mais moi je voudrais
comprendre il faut les augmenter les
salaires quand on parle du pouvoir
d'achat tout le monde est d'accord là
dessus et en même temps il ya cette
espèce de menaces de la spirale beaucoup
ont essayé de nous expliquer ça il faut
les augmenter ou pas pour éviter cette
spirale on est contre de chaussée que
qui va payer la facture c'est tout c'est
de savoir qui va payer la facture c'est
à dire qu'effectivement si vous
augmentez pas les salaires autant que
cette inflation imaginons que
l'inflation là cette année augmente en
moyenne de 5% et que ont décidé les
salaires de 3% ce qui serait bien un peu
plus que ce qu'on a eu mais malgré tout
ça veut dire vous à une perte de poids
d'achat de 2 % parce que les plus
augmente de 5% votre c'est l'argument de
3% vous appauvrissez donc ça veut dire
que si vous voulez garantir votre poids
d'achat il faut que les salaires
augmentent autant que cette inflation et
c'est là où vous arrivez dans un effet
de second tour c'est que ça augmente
qu'on a dit le coup de trop action
présenterez ça maintient le pouvoir
d'achat est serré mais ses coûts de
production de l'entente les entreprises
si elles veulent pas perdre leurs marges
elles sont obligées de répercuter sur
les prix et si les prix augmentent alors
à ce moment là pour pas perdants pour
achat les salaires doivent augmenter
cette fameuse spirale inflationniste
qu'on essaye de tenir grâce à la
politique monétaire comme d' expliquer
le gouverneur de la banque de france a
un instant et c'est ça et alors la
différence de postes choc pétrolier du
110 haies qu'il ya des mécanismes
automatiques d'indexation c'est à dire
que les salaires augmenter mécaniquement
comme l'inflation en france y'a que le
smic les autres salaires d'ailleurs ça
pose la question de la distribution sur
les salaires qui sont au dessus du smic
et c'est là son négociant l'entreprise à
l'époque vous avez automatiquement des
augmentations de salaire en fonction
l'inflation ce mécanisme a été arrêtée
en 1992 justement pour sortir de cette
spirale gestel mais la question c'est
vraiment fondamental c'est qui va payer
ce choc inflationniste c'est vraiment ça
on est bien parce que vous partiez ce
n'est que l'état se sont que l'état et
les ménages aux deux tiers état et un
tiers lui parler de l'indexation son
corps outre l'indexation
la hausse de prix cieux de l'inflation
donc sur les salaires c'est l'une des
propositions d'ailleurs de françois
ruffin qui n'est pas dans le programme
de jean luc mélenchon mais on va faire
un petit tour d'horizon puisque le
pouvoir d'achat et la priorité le thème
numéro un de ces législatives qui
propose quoi pour gérer l'urgence c'est
signé cathy guetta
à 30 jours du premier tour des
législatives le gouvernement met le
paquet sur le pouvoir d'achat chèques
alimentaires pour les plus modestes
l'indexation des retraites sur
l'inflation prolongation du bouclier
tarifaire pour le gaz et l'électricité
jusqu'à fin 2022 mais alors que les prix
flambent il n'y a pas d'urgence il
faudra attendre le projet de loi cet été
au parlement ce qui a été présenté ce
matin par bruno le maire et olivier du
soft en conseil des ministres c'est les
grandes orientations d'un projet de loi
de finances rectificative qui sera
présenté dans la foulée des élections
législatives et les engagements que j'ai
évoqué les mesures que j'ai évoquées
figureront dans ce projet de loi de
finances rectificative chacun pense
avoir trouvé la martingale pour soutenir
le pouvoir d'achat
le rassemblement national propose de
baisser la tva sur l'essence le gaz et
l'électricité et de la supprimer pour
cent produits de première nécessité
c'est marine le pen qui durant cette
campagne a imposé son thème c'est elle
qui a imposé l'urgence du pouvoir
d'achat dans le débat public et nous
allons continuer à mener le combat
l'assemblée nationale du côté de la
nouvelle union de la gauche jean luc
mélenchon prône le panier de 5 fruits et
légumes à petit prix bloqués et le smic
1400 euros nets le député françois
ruffin va encore plus loin en osant une
mesure choc l'indexation des salaires
sur l'inflation
moi je souhaite qu'ils aient une
indexation des salaires sur l'inflation
jusqu'en 1983 en a eu dans le pays une
au-delà des promesses les marges de
manoeuvre sont faibles d'autant que
l'inflation pourrait encore s'accentuer
dans les semaines à venir
alors dites-nous
pardon à la alain bazot qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire qu'est ce qui
vous semble le plus intelligent efficace
vous qui défendez les consommateurs on a
des propositions sur la fiscalité de
l'état s'était c'était ce que disait
jordan barney la série bien compris oui
alors bon je vais pas revenir sur sami
il ya un sujet qui est tabou c'est la
tva la tva l'impôt le plus injuste qui
soit tout le monde le dit on répète ça à
longueur d'année et on ne fait rien pour
limiter cette part de la fiscalité dans
zéro
pour être provisoire il ya aussi une
aberration fiscale qui est la tva sur
les taxes explique moi qui l' avons
parlé ben oui mais pas que sur l'essence
quand il ya une taxe en deux et
indépendamment de la tva il ya une tva
sur la taxe c'est 4 4 milliards 6 qui
sont prélevés avec cet axe-là nous on ne
peut pas se positionner sur l'aspect des
revenus lyall et les partenaires sociaux
bon mais le pouvoir d'achat c'est la
formation des prix et puis c'est ce que
je gagne comme un comme revenu pour pour
acheter ce qui est un certain niveau de
prix et sur le plan des niveaux de prix
donc une fois qu'on a dit sur la tva sur
l'alimentaire il ya quand même une
aberration législatives qu'on dénonce
depuis qu'elles existent qui est la loi
et galim sur le seuil de revente à perte
en france et ça n'existe nulle part en
europe nulle part dans le monde où
l'état impose une marge de 10% à la
grande distribution j'achète sens je
suis obligé de vendre 110
ça a été une ponction sur deux ans de
près de 2 milliards d'euros de pouvoir
d'achat des consommateurs là avec
l'augmentation des prix ou alors il ya
des réunions 1 toutes les semaines oui
aujourd'hui la grande minutes cher avec
la grande distribution pour
les patrons répercuter l'inflation sur
les vidant les gouttières les marges
alors que lui impose en avoir à la loi
galy ma pause 10% de marge le seuil de
revente à perte est augmenté de 10% la
motivation c'était de dire s'il
préserver de préserver kuma les
agriculteurs en quoi ça les préserve a
été la première à dire que le
ruissellement qui devait arriver tout
naturellement dans le porte monnaie des
agriculteurs qui n'ont strictement rien
vu
si je suis bien à l'ufc que choisir
c'est l'état qui doit en gros mettre la
main non marc antoine est donc le coup
mais non mais l'état ne met pas la main
au porte-monnaie la face au privé doré
c'est mignon mais pas du tout le le
seuil de revente à perte je chanterai
il impose des bénéfices des real à
grands pas mais ça c'est extrêmement
important et et bruno le maire figurez
vous il est d'accord avec cette analyse
en disant que ça finalement c'était une
aberration il va pas dire ça comme ça on
a un lobby d'enfer de la fnsea qu'est
vent debout pour garder cette mesure qui
eut une aberration totale les
agriculteurs n'en bénéficient pas allé
m'expliquer quand le le café le cacao le
nutella le coca et c est plus cher pour
le consommateur expliquez moi comment ça
peut revenir dans le revenu agricole ça
n'est jamais revenu et ça a été
ponctionné chez les consommateurs donc
voilà une des mesures il y en a d'autres
mais il faut ne pas fabriquer
artificiellement des prix élevés avec
une loi qui est complètement une loi
scélérate la grande distribution elle
est au coeur aussi de ces questions
d'inflation rafales de joie pour tout
casser les consommateurs qui sont aussi
des électeurs vont se rendre compte de
la hausse des prix qui arrive maintenant
dans la grande distribution c'est
certain peut-être deux ou trois points
sur la tva 1 la proposition de marine le
pen tient difficilement dans la mesure
où la tva est le seul prélèvement qui
est encadré par une directive européenne
et donc on ne peut pas faire n'importe
quoi avec les niveaux de télé à 2 nous
sommes en france plutôt en dessous de la
moyenne de dt la européenne donc on pour
la première nécessité réduite sur les
produits de première nécessité et puis 3
c'est la première ressource de l'état
qui en a au combien besoin quand on l'a
160 milliards de déficit donc c'est
compliqué de toucher à la tva d'autant
plus que quand on la baisse en général
on n'est pas toujours sûr de voir la
baisse des prix au final on l'a on l'a
testé déjà avec la baisse de la tva sur
les restaurateurs il ya une dizaine
d'années on a vu que les prix à la carte
n'avait finalement pas beaucoup bougé et
que c'était les marges des restaurateurs
qu'il est plutôt pris la différence
christophe ramaux ce qu'on sait c'est
que déjà toutes les mesure on va dire
d'urgence les boucliers tarifaire les
chèques énergie la hausse la remise de
18 15 à 18 centimes sur le litre
d'essence à la pompe tout ça va être
prolongée c'est bienvenu et est-ce que
ça suffit donc je pense qu'il ya je
voulais yahia là là où je serai en
désaccord complet je pense que vielle
d'état vraiment besoin de ressources
fiscales et en particulier de la tva
pour faire ce qu'il a fait en partie
avec la crise donc ça il ya eu des
bonnes choses de faites c'est à dire
pour la pour permettre aux ménages de
faire face à ceux à ce choc parce que
quand vous baisser la tva ça bénéficient
autant très riches qu'aux courses à fait
sérieux on attendait non mais les hanter
pour écouter pas les soirs dans le but
d'un ancien le ménage a nommé ces
submersibles emmanuelle mandrou
il va en bénéficier plus que ce week-end
une ville 31 mai dans son budget la
noire de son essence et pinaquy et bien
écoutez moi je préfère monsieur sénat
permet
au juge si vous permettez que je
d'ailleurs je m'interromps merci donc
moi je maintiens que le meilleur moyen
pour faire de la justice sociale
d'accord c'est pas de faire de l'anti
fiscalisme primaires c'est de dire qu'on
a besoin de ressources fiscales bien
entendu avec des assiettes large parce
que c'est très important c'est très très
important la can et ensuite et ensuite
pour répondre aux vrais besoins de 2 des
salaires il faut de mon point de vue
offert ce qui n'a pas été fait indexé
immédiatement surtout avec un choc
exceptionnel comme cela indexé
immédiatement sur l'inflation les
prestations sociales les allocations
familiales rsa aurait un peu revalorisés
mais bien en-deça de l'inflation ou
prennent vraiment on va mettre en oeuvre
un projet de loi dont il est l'égérie
valorisation du 1er avril il fallait
aller beaucoup plus loin avec d'aviation
à la françois ruffin de l'ensemble alors
je pense à vous faire a minima vous
savez moi je suis tranquille il faut
faire a minima à prendre aller plus loin
mais je pense qu'à minima il faut il
faut revoir il faut en profiter pour
c'est dans les périodes de crise qu'on
refoule le socle de nos sociétés on a
besoin d'un choc de solidarité et donc
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il faut bien
entendu revaloriser le smic et les bas
salaires l'ensemble de la grille des bas
salaires est ensuite revoir la
hiérarchie salariale au sein des
entreprises bien sûr qu'il ya des hauts
revenus ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure
enfin durant la crise on a de l'ordre de
150 milliards d parmi tout ce qu'on n'a
toujours pas retrouvé en termes de
consommation donc on peut tout à fait de
ce point de vue là trouver des recettes
fiscales monsieur du côté de la taxation
des hauts revenus qui sont épargnés qui
ne soutiennent pas le
pouvoir de façon
redistribuer ensuite mathieu plane dans
ce panel de mesures on voit bien il ya
deux leviers an les prix augmentent on
essaye de bloquer l'augmentation et les
salaires il faut les faire suivre on
essaye de trouver des incitations pour
augmenter les salaires ça peut être le
smic ça peut être des allègements de
charges qu'est ce qu'il y ait ce qui
semble le plus intelligent le plus
efficace surtout j'ai pas une réponse
définitive là dessus
déjà ce qu'il faut voir c'est
qu'effectivement quand on regarde le
bouclier tarifaire plus la baisse l'a
remis sur les prix de l'essence plus il
ya eu unanimité inflation plus un chèque
énergie on n'est quand même pas loin de
30 milliards c'est pas rien de mettre 30
milliards sur la table on n'est pas dans
le coin qu'il en coûte mais on n'est pas
non plus face à une crise qu vide je
veux dire d'un point de vue
justement la problématique aujourd'hui
c'est les déficits et la dette c'est à
dire jusqu'où on pourra répondre c'est
donc la dette va coûter plus cher était
d'emprunter des solutions
bonnes solutions circuit une fois plus à
chocs négatifs c'est un choc négatif et
il faut répondre à chocs négatifs d'une
certaine façon est de savoir comment on
n'est pas les plus fragiles quelque part
c'est plus c'est ça la vraie question en
fait il faut trouver du cbc commentaires
parmi eux il ya du ciblage il ya la
gestion d'urgence c'est ce qui est fait
avec le boucler tarifaire ou la remise
de 15 centimes mais on gère l'urgence on
sait très bien qu'on va pouvoir
maintenir dans le temps un tel
dispositif si les prix de l'énergie
restent durablement élevé donc ça veut
dire des réponses plus structurelle
ciblé mieux les ménages modestes classes
moyennes dépendant énergétiquement
investir très rapidement pour être moins
dépendants des hydrocarbures plus être
plus efficace
dans nos modes de transport c'est un peu
de sobriété donc c'est un mix global
mais ça va peut-être prendre cinq ans ça
ça prend du temps voilà l'asthme est ce
que je veux dire c'est que pour le
moment on est dans une réponse d'urgence
et on répond à l'urgence mais c'est pas
si on est face à un choc structurelles
l'urgence suffira pas les gens nés dans
un moment très particulier la en début
de quinquennat ou vous ne comprenez pas
comment on s'en sort parce que très
franchement l'équation budgétaire est
insolvable pour l'instant on est dans un
grand écart entre le récit le discours
politique et la réalité économique le
discours politique pour l'instant
gouvernement c'était la thématique du
dernier conseil des ministres du
quinquennat c'est le pouvoir d'achat on
a effectivement ce paquet pouvoir
d'achat qui va remonter les minima
sociaux graves dans un collectif
budgétaire au mobile et les retraites
les fonctionnaires qui va pérenniser les
aides à la pompe davantage ciblé c'est
la clé pour pérenniser ces aides il faut
vraiment arrêter d'arroser tout le monde
parce que toute la france n'est pas au
rsa et tout le monde n'a pas besoin des
aides à la pompe qu'il faut cibler
d'années pour 15 % d'augmentation sur un
paquet de pâtes c'est 20 centimes
l'écrasante majorité des français
peuvent subir cette inflation c'est pas
dramatique non plus mais on est dans un
discours politique en sortie de quoi
qu'il en coûte où on arrose quoi qu'il
en soit et les milliards valls comme si
on en avait plein les poches ça n'est
pas le cas et aujourd'hui christine
lagarde depuis la slovénie a confirmé
que et bien le quoi qu'il en coûte
c'était fini la bamboche financières et
monétaires s'est terminée
vous augmentez vont très probablement
passer en territoire positif d'ici la
fin de l'année est juste un chiffre une
augmentation de 1 % des taux d'intérêt
de la banque centrale européenne ces 40
milliards de charges supplémentaires
chaque année au bout de dix ans là les
taux sur la dette française ils sont
passés de zéro au mois de janvier de fin
2021 à 1,6 aujourd'hui on est pas un
pour cent on est à 1,6 et 60 milliards
dans dix ans ce que devront payer les
contribuables dans une décennie donc
attention classe il renchéri avec
l'augmentation des triais oui bien sûr
d'autant plus que non mais il y avait le
ciblage parce que le ciblage faut pas
oublier les gilet jaune et gilet jaune
s'était pas les gens les plus pauvres
s'il est classé malienne c'était des
classes moyennes et les classes moyennes
donc entendu soulage évidemment que les
gens les plus pauvres il faut qu'ils
puissent manger bon ça c'est clair mais
après quand on a arrosé large
avec un panier de de gens qui avaient de
1000 euros je crois de revenus etc là on
n'a pas ciblé parce qu'entre les gens
qui avait 2000 euros de revenus qui
habitez en ville qui utilisent les
transports en commun et pas de voiture
individuelle il n'avait pas besoin de
cet argent alors que dans les campagnes
vous avez besoin choix de remplir votre
cuve de fuel soit d'avoir une voire deux
voitures et c'est pas du luxe vous êtes
captif du fait que vous habitez à la
campagne à un point d'accord
attention à ne pas s'y blick que sur les
pauvres parce qu'il ya un bon ciblage
efficace bon écoute et en tout cas on va
s'arrêter là moi j'ai l'impression
d'avoir quand même compris un certain
nombre de choses c'est pas simple voire
même assez inquiétant je dirais vous
êtes les bienvenus qu'on voulait parce
que c'est une affaire qui me fait que tu
ne fais que commencer merci merci à vous
on va parler à présent d'un film
exceptionnel il a été présenté début
septembre à la mostra de venise il sort
en salles aujourd'hui son titre tranché
il nous immerge dans la ligne de front
au plus près en ukraine celle qui vous
avez
représente le l'endroit où se bat depuis
les soldats dans le donbass bien avant
l'invasion russe est un documentaire en
noir et blanc tourné en 2020 par le
grand reporter look bureau qui nous
rejoint dans un instant et dont voici
quelques extraits dans ce sujet signé
marco pogné
si on vous invite le bureau c'est pour
parler de votre documentaire qui résonne
tristement avec l'actualité une plongée
dans une guerre de tranchées réalisées
il ya deux ans sur la ligne de front
dans le donbass cette région à l'est de
l'ukraine en guerre depuis 2014 huit
années de combats entre l'armée
ukrainienne et les séparatistes
pro-russes
non
le clic
cet autocollant belgique la boîte tout
perdre mon
sinatra nos
[Musique]
loups bureau vous êtes journaliste mais
aussi documentariste votre adn les
terrains complexe pakistan egypte
ukraine vous aimez raconter les conflits
et ses conséquences vous arrêtez là où
les autres ne vont pas de vous nous
retenons aussi votre arrestation en
turquie en 2010 est votre tort un
reportage sur une milice kurde condamné
à 25 ans de prison pour terrorisme
vous serez libéré après 52 jours de
détention éprouvante libéré après
intervention des autorités françaises
bien sûr il ya une remise en question
énorme à ce moment-là de savoir qu'est
ce que j'avais envie de faire de ma vie
ce que j'étais prêt à prendre les
risques nécessaires pour continuer à
travailler sur des terrains de guerre ce
que entre parenthèses comme on dit le le
jeu en vaut la chandelle en fait une
question que vous trancher rapidement
dès 2020 vous retourner sur le terrain
en ukraine au plus proche du danger au
contact de la mort quatre mois passés
avec le trentième bataillon de l'armée
ukrainienne aux avant-postes attentes
ennuis bombardements dans cette guerre
de position vous partager le quotidien
de soldats cloître et cloisonnée dans
leurs tranchées votre obsession montrer
l'humanité et la fragilité de ce qu'ils
combattent
ils sont tellement
forte efficace
je suis prêt
alors le bureau il y a deux mois
volodymyr elin ce qui se disait prêt à
négocier le dombass avec moscou mais les
ukrainiens sur le front sont ils
vraiment prêts à abandonner cette région
de l'ukraine vous qui les avez côtoyé
nous attendons votre réponse
bonsoir le glow soit merci beaucoup
d'être là on va parler de ce film dans
un instant mais pour rebondir sur la
question qui vous est adressé dans ce
sujet vous qu'il est j'imagine les
côtoyer encore vous avez gardé des
contacts c'est un film qui a été tourné
en 2020 mais ce ce bataillon ce 30ème
fête 30e brigade de l'armée ukrainienne
dans le donbass aujourd'hui elle se
battra jusqu'au bout elle ne lâchera
rien elle veut revenir aux frontières
même d'avant 2014 oui alors elle se bat
jusqu'au bout pour le moment ils
survivent un peu parce que l'ampleur de
l'offensive russe est tel que en fait
ils sont dans une position défensive
maintenant l'objectif c'est de ne pas de
ne pas voilà se faire percer les lignes
par par l'offensive russe mais sur cette
brigade en particulier ce cas c'est
intéressant c'est que eux sont toujours
dans les mêmes tranchée qu'en 2020 que
dans les tranchées que je filme pour ce
film et et ils ont résisté pour le
moment malheureusement certains sont
morts déjà mais bon c'est la guerre est
effectivement oui la question c'est de
savoir est-ce qu'ils résisteront et
s'ils résistaient ce qu'ils se
contenteront des frontières près
invasion donc avec déjà sept régions du
donbass occupée c'est une ré c'est une
question assez compliqué parce qu'une
partie de l'opinion publique ukrainienne
considère de facto que le dombass fait
partie de l'ukraine et qu'il n'y aura
jamais de compromis là-dessus donc
l'être volodymyr zelensky est un peu
coincé parce qu'il sait que même si lui
devait faire des concessions quelque
part ça va lui retomber dessus après il
y aura sans doute des manifestations
ouais son opinion ne le suivra peut-être
pas là dessus d'ailleurs il l'a dit
sur cette région il ya déjà plusieurs
semaines et ne l'a pas redire
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à
vous intéresser à l'ukraine à la couvrir
cette guerre dans le donbass en 2014
après maidan oui mais en fait moi je
suis parti couvrir le mouvement maidan
en fait donc la révolution ukrainienne
en 2013 et j'étais tout jeune j'avais 23
ans et je me souviens que c'était
quelque chose qui m'avait vraiment
frappé de voir cette révolution plein
coeur de l'europe avec des idéaux très
fort de liberté de se libérer de la
corruption voilà d'avoir une nation
indépendante c'est quelque chose qui
avait fait écho un peu à mes propres
valeurs et donc j'avais décidé d'aller
voir et puis après la guerre a éclaté et
en fait d'année en année on a commencé à
s'en désintéresser parce que comme tout
lire qui perdure c'est difficile aussi
poli continuez à paraître quelque chose
s'est vu que ça vous énerver un peu
qu'on ait dit après l'invasion russe ça
y est retour de la guerre elle n'a
jamais elle n'a jamais cessé dans cette
région lui ça m'énervait un peu parce
que je pense que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui malheureusement est aussi le
résultat de huit ans de guerre qu'on n'a
pas réussi à mettre fin jeudi nous parce
qu'effectivement les occidentaux ont
leur part de responsabilité dans le
processus de paix mais effectivement il
ya des choses aussi qui les dépasse mais
en tout cas qu effectivement quand une
guerre perdure pendant huit ans à basse
intensité mais toujours attentif à voile
avec elle quand même là c'est qu'à un
moment donné le risque qu'elles éclatent
dans une ampleur inédite et très grand
et c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé
et les ukrainiens on avait totalement
conscience moi j'ai rencontré beaucoup
d'ukrainiens qui m'ont dit vous allez
voir un jour on sera en guerre contre la
russie directement ok pas s'étendre sur
presque sa part l'on sait trancher parce
que c'est c'est fascinant de voir ce
film en noir et blanc tourné en 4/3
c'est comme s'il y avait une forme de
cadre dans dans l'image elle-même
évidemment ça nous rappelle tout
l'imaginaire et c'est spectaculaire
cette passerelle avec la première guerre
mondiale 1914 vous teniez as a montré
que que ça ressemblait à la guerre de
nos grands parents ou de nos
arrière-grands-parents exactement je
pense que c'est quelque chose dont
personne n'avait conscience qu'une
guerre de tranchées pouvait avoir lieu
au 21e siècle et elle avait lieu en
ukraine et continuent d'avoir lieu dans
certains endroits en ukraine et et moi
je suis français et forcément on a tous
vu ces images dans nos livres d'histoire
dans notre imaginaire collectif dans les
films dans dans la littérature est donc
effectivement la première fois que je
suis arrivé vers 2017 et que j'ai vu
qu'en fait le front ukrainien se
transformait en une guerre de tranchées
une guerre de position ça m'a vraiment
frappé et en fait de là est né le désir
vraiment de me tourner vers le cinéma
d'avoir une une visée esthétique une
visée artistique autour du autour du
film pour nourrir ce propos pour essayer
de faire comprendre aux gens en fait
qu'est ce que c'est que la vie dans les
tranchées
il faut le dire aussi comment vous avez
tourné vous avez tourné seule caméra à
l'épaule j'ai tourné principalement seul
tout le film a été fait sans preneur de
son nom sans preneurs de sons parce
qu'en fait il ya une telle promiscuité
déjà dans les tranchées et dans les
endroits où on vit dans les bunkers que
ça aurait pas été possible d'avoir avec
moi une équipe et comment ça s'est placé
cette infiltration trois mois
normalement journalistes qui passent
quelques heures avec une escorte qu'est
ce qui s'est passé pour que voulons
bureau vous avez pu au fond restez vous
dormiez sur place avec un gilet
pare-balles c'est ça exactement mais
c'est un peu les chances de la vider les
rencontres au bon moment qu'on fait et
moi j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer un
jeune ingénieur sur maïdan justement
tout est parti de là en fait et qui
devenu ensuite militaires et qui m'a
introduit à ce bataillon à ce commandant
particulier qui a choisi de m'accepter
parmi les siens tout en avertissant pas
sa hiérarchie
il était aussi c'était aussi un proche
de mon ami de dima s'appelle dima est qu
il a eu confiance et que je pense que
foncièrement les ukrainiens ou envie
aussi de témoigner de ce qui se passe
dans leur pays ça fait ça fait très
longtemps que les ukrainiens 12 européen
regarder la guerre ne nous laissez pas
tomber commencé à mettre des sanctions
sur la demie à petit ça fait très
longtemps qui tiennent ce discours est
malheureusement delevoye que maintenant
et c'est un peu tard pour vous aussi ça
a été une épreuve
7,7 voilà cette situation d'immersion
dans l'est dans les tranchées
psychologiquement on sait que vous avez
été incarcéré dans une prison turque s
on revit ça aussi on revisite
enfermement exactement mais il ya
quelque chose que j'ai retrouvé dans les
tranchées de mon enfermement de de ma
détention puisqu'il ya ce c'est une
prison les tranchées on ne peut pas
partir parce que les soldats ils sont
entre parenthèses coincé parce qu'ils
ont souscrit un contrat et que de toute
façon il n'est pas question de se
défiler parce que quand on quand on
quitte sa position basse et c'est une
désertion et donc on va en prison donc
beaucoup de soldats ont été avait envie
de s'engager mais ne pensez pas qu'ils
se retrouveraient dans cette situation
de guerre de tranchées et c'est très
difficile pour eux alors ce qui est
intéressant aussi dans votre film c'est
que vous montrer l'humanité de ses
hommes mais aussi une femme on va en
parler montrer des scènes de la vie
quotidienne
au fond il ya une forme de normalité
aussi qui s'installe dans ce dans ce
chaos l'attend l'ennui l'amitié et même
quelques scènes assez drôle vous ne
fumez pas tant les les combats que cela
regardez cet extrait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voila
voila c'est cette humanité là vous vous
leviez film est particulièrement plus
que au fond les scènes de combat de
bombardements oui et puis je pense que
pour bien comprendre la tranche il faut
comprendre comment ces hommes et ces
sept femmes se recréer une normalité
dans un univers qui n'est pas normal
mais vous savez on avait déjà ça en 14
18 quand on lit les écrits des poilus
les lettres des produits parce que c'est
intéressant moi je les ai prises avec
moi j'ai pris des recueils de l'être et
je les ai lues dans les tranchées en
fait en ukraine et en fait j'ai retrouvé
la même chose eux aussi devaient tuer le
temps on a toujours l'impression que les
combats étaient des perpétuelles et sans
arrêt en fait non les poilus devait
aussi recréer une normalité dans leurs
tranchées et c'est ça qui a un qui est
important parce que quand on veut on
essaie de se recréer une normalité ben
ça danse ça n'en devient que d'autant
plus choquant quand tout d'un coup la
mort frappe parce qu'effectivement ils
sont sans cesse rappelée à la guerre
même si lé bruit assourdissant des
déflagrations perpétuel et des
bombardements dans ce film c'est le son
aussi c'est très important je voudrais
qu'on s'arrête un instant pour terminer
sur oksana c'est comme ça qu'on dit
c'est la seule femme seule date dans ce
dans ce trentième bataillon de l'armée
ukrainienne je crois qu'on a on a une
photo d'elle on l'a aperçue dans le long
extrait dans l'extrait précédents qui
étaient les comment elle arriva à se
retrouver là engagé à oksana s'engage en
fait par un parcours de vie qui qui qui
lui arrive
ça n'a en fait elle avait deux enfants à
sa charge et un mari qui la battait donc
en fait voilà un moment donné à s'est
retrouvé tout seul à l'affût et que ses
enfants et elle n'avait plus de
ressources financières est en fait
malheureusement en ukraine c'est une
société dans laquelle il est dur de
vivre avec un salaire moyen qui est très
très faible on parle de deux cents 200
euros par part moi donc donc en fait
elle a décidé de s'engager dans l'armée
a aussi pour des raisons économiques
alors bien sûr elle partageait tout
toutes ces raisons patriotiques qui
pousse des gens à s'engager et de
prendre les armes mais il y avait cet
aspect au cycle économique important
elle est profonde elle est plus âgée
mais c'est extrêmement cg vu à quel
point c'était dur pour elle en tant que
femme d'être dans ces tranchées parce
qu'on a forcément des problèmes
d'intimité qui sont très grande
promiscuité donc quand tous les hommes
sont autour de vous tout le temps c'est
difficile et puis et puis effectivement
la eu un rôle elle est un peu plus âgé
que la plupart des soldats donc elle a
eu un rôle très vite deux mamans et puis
après il faut dire aussi que une partie
de la société ukrainienne est encore
assez patriarcale donc effectivement une
femme dans les tranchées une femme
soldat tu ça fait toujours parler et les
soldats passé beaucoup de temps à se
moquer d'elle mais elle était avec des
hommes à cet endroit là précisément qui
était plus un peu plus ouvert d'esprit
que dans certains endroits et au final
elle arrivait quand même à faire son
signe entre vous qui revenait du cren
aujourd'hui comment vous voyez ce
conflit on a l'impression que poutine
s'enfonce dans une guerre longue
moi je ne vois pas comment poutine s'en
sort parce que même là j'en suis j'en
suis revenue juste il manger et il ya
dix jours j'ai su rester un peu plus de
trois semaines il ya eu trois quatre
villages qui ont été pris par là par les
russes il n'avance quasiment pas ça se
fait au cas par cas et et rio prix au
prix un
humain et matériel extrêmement fort donc
effectivement peut-être même qui
peut-être effectivement qu'il a un
agenda haut à long terme mais ça pose
aussi des questions de ce qu'il aura les
capacités militaires de deux voies la
logistique de ré avitailler toute son
armée de continuer à résister
se mettre dans la tête que plus le temps
passe plus la méridienne pour le moment
en tout cas reçoit l'aide de l'occident
est donc plus à l'est à même de faire
face à ce qui se passe merci vous bureau
vous rester avec moi parce que ça va
vous intéresser c'est lors de nos partis
pris nos affranchi qui vont nous
rejoindre ce soir on va parler politique
avec elsa mondain gavap dans son carnet
de campagne elle va nous détailler les
ambitions de marine le pen aux
législatives le coup de gueule de fatiha
boudia lattes sur le burqini dans les
piscines à grenoble et puis je disais ça
va vous intéresser parce qu'isabelle la
serbe va vous parler de l'ukraine
isabelle qui selon elle les ukrainiens
ont déjà gagné bonsoir mesdames bonsoir
noah franchi au féminin pluriel alors où
sont mes notes on va commencer avec vous
ou elsa ça y est je me retrouve comme
tous les soirs carnet de campagne des
législatives ce soir on s'intéresse à
marine le pen qui a présenté ses
différents candidats investis dans cette
course là qu'elle a les moyens d'être
ambitieuse dans cette dans cette
élection baïse espère en tout cas elle a
présenté cinq cent soixante neuf
candidats nous on est et on s'est rendu
au siège du rassemblement national avec
clément perreault c'est jordan bardella
qui préside le parti il avait donc
convié la presse pour parler des
candidats investis mais aussi de la
stratégie du parti pour l'anecdote on
était dans une salle toute petite bien
serré il a même fallu sortir des chaises
supplémentaires c'était vraiment pas un
grand show c'était quelque chose de très
classique très simple un pupitre et une
affiche avec un message important la
seule opposition à maquereau on a
compris que le rassemblement national et
ben on entendait bien récupérer les
habits de premier opposant à emmanuel
macron des habits portés par jean luc
mélenchon alors on a demandé à jordan
bardella mais s'il l'a voulait vraiment
la victoire pour ces élections
législatives mais nous faisons campagne
pour la victoire par circonscription
nous on campagne pour faire élire
partout en france des députés du rnd ça
c'est un faux procès qui nous est fait
nous faisons campagne pour
arriver en tête au premier tour partout
en france dans les circonscriptions et
pour remporter des sièges de députés
pour avoir demain un groupe puissant qui
va peser face à manier la con qui sera
en capacité de se faire l'écho le
porte-voix du quotidien de plus en plus
difficile des français qui est aussi le
bilan de monsieur macron donc nous
sommes au contraire très déterminés à
remporter ces élections législatives
pourquoi on a posé cette question myriam
et bien c'est parce qu'on voit bien
qu'il ya un décalage entre la stratégie
de jean luc mélenchon qui veut la
victoire qui veut une majorité et à la
fin être élu premier ministre et puis le
rassemblement national qui dit vouloir
tout juste un peu plus de députés
qu'avant et si bien que marine le pen ça
l'exaspère un peu puisque on en vient à
lui demander si elle elle veut pas non
plus être premier ministre écouter ce
qu'elle répond jean luc mélenchon ne
sera jamais premier ministre en revanche
si un certain nombre de français votent
pour lui il peut transformer la scène
nationale en zad voilà et ça je ne le
souhaite pas donc la vraie question
c'est quelle opposition à emmanuel
macron fifa derrière transformer
l'assemblée nationale en za de zad c'est
à dire avec les défenseurs des black
blocks les défenseurs de du burkina à la
piscine ceux qui veulent désarmer la
police ceux qui veulent ouvrir les
prisons voile après deux semaines de
repos ou de recul on voit que marine le
pen entend bien occuper l'espace on
verra ce que ça donne c'est vrai que
mode de scrutin ne lui est pas favorable
en général alors autres petites infos
législatives match de personnalités dans
la 7e circonscription du val de marne
oui on l'a appris aujourd'hui la
ministre des sports est ancienne nageuse
roxana maracineanu se lance dans la
campagne des législatives dans la 7e
circonscription du val de marne et elle
fera face à une candidate aussi
médiatique rachel kéké candidate pour la
nuque baisse ou la nuque visiblement ce
n'est pas encore tranchée c'était une
des porte parole des femmes de chambre
qui avaient fait grève pendant de longs
mois contre les hôtels ibis donc affaire
à suivre merci beaucoup merci elsa le
retour de fatiha vous devez là dedans
c'est ta vie s'y retrouver parmi eux
c'est la même chose pour moi pour nous
tous alors nous parler quelle surprise
on était presque sûr du burkina grenoble
n'êtes pas très contente de ce qui est
dit eric piolle le maire de la ville oui
et puis le télescopage est terrible
parce que la même semaine eric piolle
défend le droit de porter le burqini
dans les piscines et la même semaine les
barbus food afghanistan impose de
nouveaux la burqa aux femmes maintenant
je compare les deux parties entre les
deux il n'ya pas une différence de
nature il ya juste une différence de
degré c'est la société du voile dans
tous les cas qui consiste à criminaliser
le coup des femmes en en faisant un
organe génital total alors rattrapé par
la patrouille et puis par l'exemple
allemand fiole promet la liberté d'être
seins nus dans le même bassin que celles
qui seront burkini on écoute vous
pourrez venir les seins nus comme vous
dans les piscines de grenoble et vous
pourrez venir en maillot couvrant si
vous voulez vous protéger du soleil ou
pour des raisons est
descendu tout est en fait même bassin
c'est la loi c'est de l'inclusion ça
avec cette équivalence idiote entre les
bulls et la voilure comme si c'était sa
l'unique alternative qui s'impose aux
femmes l'excès de pudeur contre l'excès
d'impudeur et je ne pense pas que des
familles répondent se baigner seins nus
dans les piscines avec les lits des
hommes qui seraient assez excités qui
les agréent serait mais ça éric appadu
on pensait donc sérique cher eric tu te
foutrais pas un peu de notre gueule
sincèrement eric piolle sera l'homme du
burkini et pas de l'écologie est la
seule des croissances qu'il aura permis
c'est celle de la dignité des femmes
redisons le burqini ce n'est pas une
affaire de laïcité la laïcité
circonscrite dans l'espace et dans le
temps c'est une affaire de dignité des
femmes et celle ci n'a aucune limite
deux genres deux sexes de durée ou de
religion et quand on change une loi une
règle il faut s'interroger sur l'usagé
qu'en font les activistes qui en sont à
l'origine de son adoption mais il faut
aussi s'interroger sur les faits qu'on
aura cette fois sur les plus faibles que
ce soit sur les plus petit que soi sur
les plus vulnérables que soit qu'elle va
faire c'est toi bats burqini va se
généraliser parce qu'il y aura une
pression communautaire sur les autres
femmes qui se verront reprocher de
vouloir nager comme des mets criante au
milieu de mes craintes de nager haram
voilà avec l'accent plutôt que de nager
elle halal et cette maj l aile basse et
comme la nage papillon qui deviendra une
épreuve olympique
alors que les femmes musulmanes sont
justement soumises en permanence aux jo
de l'authenticité de la pureté de la
pudeur de la discrétion merci beaucoup
on vous retrouve très en forme merci
merci fatiha alors je signale que la
petite vidéo des rituels que vous avez
découvert donc avec l'excellente
question jean-pierre montanay cédant
politique à table
à retrouver demain c'est sa sueur sur
notre antenne avec brigitte boucher et
ce sera à 14 heures merci fatiha on
enchaîne avec l'ukraine alors j'imagine
que vous connaissez tous les deux vous
êtes peut-être déjà rencontré sur un
plateau de télévision vous nous dites ce
soir isabelle lasserre les ukrainiens
vont gagner ont gagné la guerre écoutez
en tout cas vont gagner la guerre en
tout cas c'est désormais une possibilité
souvenez-vous myriam quand vladimir
poutine a déclaré sa guerre le 24
février
beaucoup de gens pensaient que les
forces russes ne ferait qu'une bouchée
des combattants d'ukrainiens 77 jours
plus tard le rapport de forces est
toujours en défaveur des ukrainiens bien
entendu médecine n'est plus le même les
forces russes ont dû revoir à la baisse
leurs objectifs militaires et pour se
concentrer sur le dombass et n'ont pas
réussi à prendre kiev à faire tomber
volodymyr zelensky même marioupol dont
on annonce la chute depuis plusieurs
semaines n'est toujours pas tombée parce
qu'on a un millier de combattants qui
résiste de manière farouche dans
l'usinage opstal l'armée russe a perdu
lui ni le navire amiral moskva elle a
perdu plus de 1000 chars et selon l'état
major ukrainien 24000 sommes en face les
ukrainiens entraînée par les occidentaux
depuis 2014 reçoivent de plus en plus
d'armes qui sont de plus en plus
efficaces et qui leur permettent parfois
de reprendre l'ascendant sur les russes
la victoire est là aussi une dimension
morale elle est aussi morale parce que
la guerre c'est aussi c'est également un
affrontement des volontés la volonté de
plus en plus forte du côté des
ukrainiens qui ne doute plus de leur
victoire elle s'affaiblit au contraire
chez les combattants russes qui dont
beaucoup s'interrogent aujourd'hui sur
le sens de la guerre alors ya deux
images qui ont résumé le lundi 9 mai
jour de commémoration de la victoire
soviétique contre le nazisme la
différence d'énergie qui sort des
pouvoirs à kiev et à moscou on voyait
d'un côté un vladimir poutine dû
refermer statique tourné vers le passé
prononcé un discours de rancoeur
historique et de l'autre côté volodymyr
zelensky dans la rue le torse bombé le
visage déterminé qui n'avait jamais paru
aussi sûr de lui lorsque vous pensez que
la lumière poutine la neige a perdu
d'une certaine façon cette guerre en
partie oui il a échoué donc à faire
tomber zelensky et la capitale il
voulait faire rentrer l'ukraine dans le
giron russe il apprécie pitt dans les
bras de lieux qui se demande aujourd'hui
comment la faire rentrer le plus vite
possible dans la grande famille
européenne ils voulaient tuer l'otan il
l'a ressuscité
peut-être qu'un jour la dîmière poutine
sera obligé de rendre des comptes si ce
n'est à la justice internationale
du moins à sa population mais la voilà
quand on a dit ça si la victoire des
ukrainiens est désormais envisageable
elle aura de toute façon un coût
extrêmement élevé en vies humaines et en
destructions et ce coût risque de
augmenter au fur et à mesure
qu'augmentera la frustration de vladimir
poutine qui lui a besoin aussi à tout
prix d'une victoire or face aux
difficultés des forces armées
ukrainiennes à renouveler leurs
combattants est-ce qu'on est finalement
aussi sûr que le temps joue en faveur
des ukrainiens en demi-teinte finalement
7,7 cette conclusion ils appellent
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous pensez
au fond d'eux de cette analyse est ce
que parrot font envie très sucré mien
réussissent avance ne se fasse pas
massacrer est-ce qu'on a une objectivité
dans la manière dont on regarde ce
conflit depuis depuis l'occident depuis
l'europe est ce qu'on peut dire que
voilà la résistance et elle le soutient
est telle que le rapport de forces est
un peu inversés je sais pas si le
rapport de force est vraiment à verser
en tout cas ce qui est ce qui est sûr
c'est que la résistance est réellement
là les ukrainiens se bat comme tous
enfin moi j'ai énormément d'amis qui
sont partis sur le front et c'est pas
quelque chose d'anodin de prendre une
arme et de partir sur le froid j'en ai
vu énormément le faire dans mon
entourage déjà mais
peut-être que les ukrainiens gagneront
je pense que c'est réellement possible
après la question c'est plutôt à quel
prix le pays déjà complètement d'il ya
plus de deux mille missiles qui sont
tombées sur les infrastructures du pays
depuis le début la guette de la guerre
sainte et à deux mois donc on peut
imaginer si la guerre durera 1 2 en coop
combien de missiles vont avec des
exactions avec des exactions des crimes
sur les enfants la table parlent déjà de
6 ans 1600 milliards pour reconstruire
du pays enfin voilà
vous pensez que la justice peut passer
non france envoie les enquêteurs on se
dit mais comment ils vont faire pour que
c'est très bien c'est très bien de
documenter les crimes de guerre le
problème c'est qu'on sait très bien
après qu'ils ne seront pas jugés
figurent à rien après est-ce qu'on n'a
jamais jugé c'est surtout que le temps
de la justice
internationale n'est pas du tout celui
de la guerre pendant les guerres des
balkans il avait fallu attendre 15 ans
20 ans que slobodan milosevic radovan
karadzic et ratko mladic les chefs de
guerre de l'époque soit jugé au tp
isoler soutien de leur population c'est
le seul à seul variable est ce le sport
qu'on peut avoir c'est russe se
débarrasse eux mêmes oui mais pour
l'instant vladmir ce bling à poutine a
aussi le soutien de la population et
puis il y avait en plus 2014 il ya eu
déjà à des crimes montbovon rappelle le
m h 17 l'avion qui avait été abattu par
les séparatistes que dont ça a été
prouvé par un tribunal néerlandais
qu'ils étaient russes le missile mais
qu'est ce qui se passe après ça alors
c'est important de documenter
effectivement c'est une trace dans
l'histoire on doit le faire mais mais
effectivement ce mois je me pose des
questions sur ce que j'aurai quelque
chose après quoi et vous qui en revenait
ils ont l'impression d'être vraiment
soutenus par les européens par les
français maintenant oui maintenant oui
ça a tardé mais oui bien sûr parce que
ça fait des années que les ukrainiens
essayé d'avertir l'europe pour leur dire
regardez il ya une guerre chez nous
regardez comment la propagande russe a
dépeint les ukrainiens pendant plusieurs
années et ce qui explique aussi en
partie de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui la
haine des fois qu'on les cons les russes
envers les ukrainiens et puis ça fait
très longtemps que les ukrainiens 10
n'essayez pas de faire de nouveaux
contrats avec la russie on a vu dans
scream 2 tu sais ça continue et on a
continué à 100 notre aveuglement un
travail le mans et eux le voit
après voilà ils sont pas mauvaises
langues ils sont très contents ils sont
très heureux quelque part de voir ce
soutien international mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya une petite amertume quand même
dernière question puisqu'il nous reste
un peu moins d'une minute et abel il ya
deux jours le président français a
douché un peu les espoirs de l'ukraine
un jour entrer dans dans le club dans
l'union européenne c'était le bon moment
dire ça alors que
ça a été assez mal accueillie non
seulement ni crème mais aussi à l'est de
l'europe cette partie les parties de
l'europe orientale et qui voudraient
aller beaucoup plus vite dans
l'intégration de l'écrin nous essayer de
la moldavie de la georgie mais de toute
façon en même temps il faut pas raconter
de bêtises
l'ukraine ne peut pas rentrer en cinq
minutes dans l'union européenne donc ce
serait faire des fausses promesses que
que de le dire c'est à dire d'abord il a
fait valoir plusieurs années pour que
l'ukraine soit prête au niveau
économique et ensuite quel problème des
balles tempe des balkans occidentaux qui
attendent eux aussi depuis plus
longtemps et comment donc on est en
train d'essayer de 2,2 un excès faire
des formules alors est-ce que ce que les
ukrainiens aimerait la maintenance est
en fait non pas l'entrée directement
dans l'union européenne mais mais au
moins que le statut soit s'unir en est
pas encore là il ya des divisions au
sein de l'union européenne comme
d'habitude le bureau
voilà ce film les tranchées voulez vous
l'avez fait pour qui pour la jeune
génération pour qui qui vous aimeriez
vraiment voilà le tout le monde le voit
parce qu on est tous en train de
découvrir ce qui se passe voilà
franchement même si des spécialistes
voilà depuis deux mois on est embarqué
dans ce mode on parce que tout le monde
découvre qu est-ce que quel est votre
message aux points je les fais pour nous
européens je les fais pour montrer que
en europe depuis huit ans des jeunes de
mon âge parts sur le franc se battre et
c'est pas quelque chose d'anodin la
société ukrainienne est profondément
meurtrie par ces huit années de guerre
il ya énormément de traumatismes déjà
qu'ils sont présents et malheureusement
ça va continuer et mais voilà j'ai fait
ce film parce que on ne parlait plus
l'ukraine et malheureusement c'est
maintenant voilà une envergure nouvelle
mais mais c'était important à l'époque
aussi ça sort en salles aujourd'hui ça
va voyager dans le festival sûrement ça
s'appelle les tranchées merci beaucoup
merci à vous les affranchis merci au
bureau fin de cette émission pour
l'avoir ou la revoir ya la chaîne
youtube des cp tout de suite votre
soirée documentaire les dernières
batailles du pape françois un film de
constance colonna cesari très belle
soirée allemand
[Musique]